[Music]  if you were thinking of watching house  of cards or stranger things on your  switch then you may want to curb your  expectations  Nintendo confirmed that its upcoming  console won't have any video services  including Netflix at launch I'm Matt and  this GameSpot news update might not be  available on the switch either Nintendo  released a statement to video gamer comm  saying all of our efforts have gone  toward making the Nintendo switch system  an amazing dedicated video game platform  so it will not support any video  streaming services at launch however  support for video streaming services is  being considered for a future update the  Nintendo switch launches on March 3rd  for $300 at the time of this video it  has a launch lineup of 6 games including  the Legend of Zelda breath of the wild 1  to switch and the binding of issac  afterbirth Plus for more news and  information about the switch stay tuned  to game spot